[Music]
melody is in Denver hi melody how are
you I feel like great how are you doing
Dave better than I deserve what's up
well great I had spoken to you earlier
this year I was a very different person
when I called and since toccata go back
a little bit I I'm taking care of my son
who is mentally ill and I had a very
very extremely low paying job well since
that time God has blessed and I work for
another law firm making forty thousand
dollars more so yeah great I am also
working on my real estate investing to
get that really up and going again
because I know I can do it mm-hmm
I was calling because I am like a
die-hard now on the every dollar and so
I'm making like seventy six thousand s
micros now yay as opposed to thirty six
and so my debt as I stated before was I
have student loans which are about sixty
thousand and then I have the IRS which
is like nineteen thousand so it's about
seventy nine thousand right there so I
have my I'm in fact I'm actually looking
at my every dollar right now and I have
every penny and I'm also at either so I
just basically want to know do I need to
budget anything as far as an allowance
for myself or do I just need to stay you
know full speed ahead with what I'm
doing well I mean a small amount we
don't have to put much in there but you
need to have a little wiggle room
nothing big nothing but I mean I mean
even if it's fifty bucks or something
you know it don't have to be 5000 or 500
you know but just to give yourself a
little bit of wiggle room just to
little bit of steam release is a good
idea as a part of your budgeting
situation but obviously the more you
budget in that category the less you've
got to pay down on the debt and so we
don't want to overdo it but but it is
healthy to have a little bit of wiggle
room in your budget because you put your
some money aside in the miscellaneous
category is really what it comes down to
just kind of a catch-all category people
tend to overdo that category or under do
it under doing it meaning they put zero
in there which really just doesn't work
you know you don't live your life that
way that's not a realistic life or then
they tend to overdo it and go well I'm
just gonna put a big chunk in there and
that way I can kind of really do what I
want to do anyway and then go around
screw off and not get out of debt and
that's putting too much in there so what
I you know just make sure you're putting
us this small amount in there like you
know fifty bucks something in that range
and your situation you're single single
mom you know it's not gonna require a
lot for you to have a little bit of an
outlet to let some steam off good job
well done
coach it's gonna be okay told you you
were gonna make it
Wow